des Anglo montréalais.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Montréé.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.é.
- J'adore Montréal. C'est dans
mes os, c'est dans mon âme.- Jet
comme une Québécoise, bilingue
Québécoise, si ça peut être
une identité.
moi, je veux vivre en français
et en anglais.
- Quand  p p p p p p p p p p p ,
je ne m'attends pas d'être
servn n n anglais. Je parle
en français. Puis ça, pour moi,
je trouve que c'est la réalité
typique de la plupart des
Montréalais, Montréalaisicicici.
Allô! Ça va?
- Oui, merci. Je vais prendre
un café pour emporter,
s'il te plaît.
- Parfait!
Montréal, a vécu sa jeunesse
en Grèce et elle est revenue
au Canada à l'âge adulte.
Elle a choisi Montréal
pour sa diversité
et elle apprécie les effets
de la Loi 101.
TOULA DRIMONIS, journaliste
que je connais sont bilingues.
Tous les Allophones
que je connais sont presque
tous trilingues. Et d'ailleurs,
une "success story".
- Journaliste en milieu
anglopho, , , , , , , , , , , ,r
les Autochtones et les nouveaux
ars.s.s.s.
menace, comme les immigrants
sont une menace pour la langue
française, ça empêche les gens
de se sentir comme chez nous,
d'avoir ce sentiment
papapapartenance. J'ai appris
le français parce que pour moi,
c'était une affaire d'amour.
Je voulais comme vraiment,t t t♪
- Dave Kaufman est un autremont.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ardent défenseur de sa ville,
toujours prêt à faireiririririr
une musique francophone
à ses amis.
DAVID KAUFMAN,
- Quand on dit qu'on est
des enfants deesesesesest
qu'on connaît l'importance de
la langue française. Et on sait
que c'est
le futur du Québec de parler
français, d'avoir leurs
industries en ..................
Le Montréal de mes parents ou
grands-parents, où c'était pas
mais "St-Lawrence boulevard",
et que tu n'allais pas à l'est
de Papineau. C'est pas
l l l l l l que je connais.
"Welcome to the show..."
- Pour lui, les s s s s s entre
Anglophones et Francophones ont
toujours été faciles à Montréal.
Mais il gegegegegegegegegegegeg.
c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c ,
beaucoup d'Anglophones ont dit s
problème pour nous, ça."
Il n'est pas représentats,s,s,s6
a été adoptée.
- Le projet de loi numéro 96
est adopté.
- C'est du populisme, c'est du
ethno-nationalisme et c'est pas
bo m m m m m m m m m m m m m m e
souverainisme que je souviens
esesesesesesesse.
e e e e e e e e l'Office
québécois de la langue française
confirment régulièrementtititite
du travail, surtout à Montréal.e
la majorité des Anglo-Québécoisn
de personnes.
- Quand je vois la vitalité
du français, la cult
francophone, la littérature
québécoise, que j'aime autant,
j'ai un peu de l
que le français est vraiment
en danger.
- Et si tu veux qu
ne fais plus de bébés. Mais si
c'est un décli
française, je ne vois pas ça
du tout.
- Moi, de ma part, je
qu'elle est menacée, mais c'est
mon expérience personnelle.
♪ ♪ ♪vavavavavavavavavavavavava,
je parle français. Que ça soit
à Monececececececececec.
Moi, c'est ça, la langue dans
laquelle je vis ma vie depuis
leususususususususususususususu.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Anna Frances Meyer a 28 ans et
vient d'une famille anglophone.
Elle a étuntntntntntntntntntntnt
francophone qui l'ont amenée
à frarererererererererellement,
- C'est comme pas un enjeu
J'ai l'impression que le
français est vraiment en bonne
santé, que les gens qui sont
♪ ♪ ♪
- Bonjour, M. Grey.
- Bonjour, entrez!
- Ça va bien?
dededededededededededededededede
- Le français est supposémentait
pas en danger. Les gens
ont réagi à la comparaisonndndns
et immigrants sont obligés f f .
Donc, ça ne peut pas
disparaître.
- Cet avocat, grand défenseur
des droits et libertés, a été
dans le passé un pourfendeur de
1919191919191919191919191919191.
Aujourd'hui, il s'insurge contre
dans son ensemble.didididididid,
par exemple, qui est malade
dans un hôpital : "Monsieur,
d'Anglophone de souche pour que
je puisse vous traiter en
anglais?" Mais quelle absurdité!
C'eseeeeeeeeeeee
qui me dérange. J'ai voté pour
les partis indépendantistes.
nationalisme ethnique, c'est
l'identité. C'est la crainte
que le nationalism
au pouvoir au Québec.
d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d s
public du premier ministreécécéc
référendaire de 1995. Un
discours qui visait à rassurer .
semblent réclamer aujourd'hui
une bonne part des Anglophones
et des Allophones de la part
du gouvernement.
- Ça peut pas se fa
noirceur. Ça doit être un débat
en incluant nous, s'il vous
plaît. On est pl
besoin des lois. Je comprends
la raison pour les lois.
- Donc, peut-être, il faut qu'ot
si on veut y aller dans
une culture de non-animosité
et d'entraide, et de peut-être,
finalement, casser la rupture
entre les deux solitudes.
♪ ♪